Notre envoyée spéciale
Marie-Ève Bédard.
- C'est une position
stratégique. À la frontière
de l'Irak et de la province
semi-autonome du Kurdistan,
le poste d'observation est
encore essentiel pour contrer
les cellules dormantes
de l'État islamique.
Mais ce ne sont pas ceux qui
restent du groupe terroriste
qui sont responsables
de la destruction totale
de cette base fortifiée.
"Jamais nous n'aurions pensé
que l'Iran oserait attaquer
ici", dit ce commandant.
(explosion)
C'était le 28 septembre
dernier. Les premiers drones
iraniens ont frappé, puis
des tirs de missiles ont suivi.
Ardawan n'a pas pu
se mettre à l'abri à temps.
Il a été blessé à la jambe
et à la main. Mais la plus
profonde de ses blessures,
c'est en lui qu'il la porte.
Neuf de ses collègues
sont morts ce jour-là.
"Ça nous a fait très mal, dit-
il. Je ne peux pas me résoudre
à dire qu'ils sont des martyrs
maintenant. Nous étions ensemble
tous les jours."
(cris)
En Iran, le gouvernement
accuse les milices armées kurdes
iraniennes installées en Irak,
comme celle du Parti de
la liberté du Kurdistan,
d'avoir fomenté l'expression de
colère dans les rues des régions
majoritairement kurdes d'Iran.
Une accusation qui ne surprend
pas le général Yazdanpanah.
Mais s'il soutient son peuple
et l'appel au changement
de régime, il nie toute
forme d'aide militaire
au soulèvement populaire.
"Si on attaque les nôtres,
qu'ils sont tués, qu'on
leur tire dessus, dit-il, c'est
notre devoir de lesosoutenir.
Nous leur demandons de rejeter
cette dictature et ce génocide
mais des combats armés, ça, non,
ce n'est pas la solution."
L'Iran prproche au Kurdistan
irakien d'héberger quelque
3000 combattants kurdes
d'origine iranienne,
des terroristes à combattre,
pour Téhéran.
Un discours qui vise
à détourner l'attention
de ce qui se passe chez eux,
croit le général.
"L'Iran blâme toujours
ses problèmes sur les pays
voisins et d'autres pays.
Ils disent que ce sont
les États-Unis, le Canada,
le Royaume-Uni, Israël,
les pays arabes", dit-il.
Le général n'est pas prêt
à prendre les armes contre
l'armée iranienne, mais
il demande l'aide militaire
de la communauté internationale.
Tous ces soldats étaient
aux premières lignes de la lutte
contre le groupe État islamique
au sein de la Coalition
internationale. Aujourd'hui,
ils se demandent, amers,
où sont passés leurs alliés.
"Personne de la Coalition
n'est venu, déplore-t-il,
mais l'espace aérien ici,
il est à qui? À l'Iran ou
à la coalition internationale?"
(aboiement)
Une question qui trahit
l'amertume de ceux qui,
il y a quelques années
à peine, pouvaient compter
sur la présence de soldats
étrangers, comme des Canadiens,
sur cette même base militaire.
Mais aujourd'hui, les regards
sont ailleurs, déplore-t-il.
L'invasion de l'Ukraine par
la Russie accapare l'attention
de la communauté internationale.
Ce serait une erreur, dit
le commandant, de croire que
l'Iran n'y joue pas, là aussi,
un rôle clé de déstabilisation.
Un message qu'il répète
depuis longtemps.
"L'Iran alimente le terrorisme
dans la région, dit-il,
mais vous n'avez pas écout
Maintenant que les drones
iraniens sont en Ukraine,
vous réalisez que l'Iran
est une grande mene.e.
Si l'Iran n'est pas frappé
et arrêté chez-lui, il ira
dans d'autre pays, encore."
Les attaques de Téhéran en
sol irakien ont fait au moins
17 morts et une cinquantaine
de blessés depuis septembre
dernier, depuis la fronde qui
se maintient partout en Iran.
En ça, ils ne sont pas
différents de leurs compatriotes
en Iran, malgré l'uniforme,
les armes et la distance.
Ici Marie-Eve Bédard,
Radio-Canada,
au Kurdistan irakien.